the first film's I remember seeing was
Charlie Chaplin Toto have a feeling
we're not in Kansas anymore friday the
13th part two I was two years old I
remember because it started me of my
love for horror films the Soviet Union
in the 1980s I wasn't exposed to too
many Hollywood films one of my most
vivid memories from that time was when I
was visiting friends in Poland and I
watched Dirty Dancing for the first time
and I realized just how much we missing
good will hunting I remember watching
that with me and feeling like I could do
anything that I wanted to do in my life
but that it didn't matter where I came
from I think that's the thing that's so
important for every guy you to believe
in family movies are important because
it shows someone's feelings and the way
that everyone can enjoy a film that
moves changed my life was war games that
was my new I wanted to be in technology
and now
I'm a close the park looks down Assad on
my fifteenth birthday basically
awakening to the idea that you would be
more than just entertainment it could be
worse when Mateos came out I went with a
good friend of mine to the movies and it
was completely new impact on us we left
the cinnamon Madoff I was able to speak
move out it because when I first saw it
kind of just blew my mind that had no
idea of movies could be like that the
movie that laughs and lasting impact on
me is the hangover the first film I
never saw it was mighty mouse here i
come to save the day and i felt as if i
wanted to save the day as well many
years later because i have tried to save
the day I found myself in exile from
Chile where terrible things were
happening and another film came to save
me it was missing by costa-gavras
because when I could do is I could go
into any congressional office any person
could influence and say have you seen
Missy and they were saying yes and I
said okay let's start from there
how do we change the situation I thought
the movements because it gives me
something to do it mines my motivation I
can sit there and look at what you're
doing the character in the film and
pretend i'm doing it pretending I'm
saying what you're saying living your
life mini then your father rebounder
fulfilled called gajal deal this film is
unique because the most of the actors in
this film are real Roma with really
portrays the difficult life of these
people in a Miss ability to command the
Transformers ad from michael bay after
watching this movie i decided to come to
here to study filmmaking cinema paradiso
reminds me of my childhood we had a very
small cinema and every time a girl
appear we all would lean forward to try
to pick up her skirt obviously we didn't
see anything and was very frustrating
swingers program to curl assault film as
like as neat it made me think I needed
to be more about me you must about doing
set about a girl
13 it taught me how to control myself
becoming a teenager
able to gather round you want any really
great athletes and we knew that that was
a dream that was attainable watching
them
regreso saludo stage rocket otay kappa
sigma who you gonna call ghostbusters
the mother's closet in my room because
it's a story of the mothers of the
disappeared and i was a disappeared
myself in argentina's it's about these
women who march across the government
house and demanded to know where the
children were the City of God until that
point I didn't understand the phrase
life is a shape and the causes were
clear his poverty and neglect casablanca
had a nice and I learned the war and
revolution is about love it's not just
about violence it's not just about
resistance but it's about doing the
things that you love loving the
personals then you do
and we watch movies not because it's
cute but because we are members of the
human race and the human race is filled
with passion
you